hello everyone and welcome to the game
you've all been waiting for it said
England versus Oliver Sefolosha the two
classful games have been run out they go
into the rapid tiebreaks
for the first rapid the game ding gets
the white pieces and well let's just see
what happened so ding opens with Knight
to f3 we have a d5b 4 by dink Knight to
f6 we have C 4 and E 6 the Queen's
Gambit the client is on the board we
might as well start every video a video
with the Queen's Gambit a client on the
board Knights the c3 and the Bishop to
e7 now we have Bishop to f4 so not going
for Bishop to g5 what black would
immediately go for something like c5 but
we have castles by ali riza III and
Knight B to d7 Bishop to e2 ding also
prepares the castle and now dink
d captures on c4 now that the bishop has
been developed you force the bishop to
lose the tempo rush of characters on c4
not right away but dink castles there's
no rush as b5 you cannot defend it the
night already covers b5 c5 by ferocious
D characters on c5 Knight captures and
now Bishop captures on c4 nicely
recapturing that pawn and offering the
Queen trade oh there is a trait with
Queen captures and e1 rook captures an D
1 and now b6 putting more defense to the
night here on c5 and also preparing to
finca to the lights worship with Bishop
to d7
Bishop to be son and it's not a problem
since you don't have to worry about the
rock infiltrating both of the Knights
are covering the d7 square Bishop to d6
biding offering a trade of bishops and
you can't really not trade here for
example something like rook to a
defending Knight b5 he goes after it c7
or something like that so best is just a
trade route capture son b6 and now
Bishop to b7 and here rook a to d1 it's
interesting there are a lot of a lot of
games have reached this position for
example at a job of head this end game
against smart that the game ended in a
draw Wesley so also headed against her
job of that ended in a draw a smirnoff
headed against Yaakov in Co Rd ontari
head
- and all of those games ended in a row
but this is doing versus fit OSHA and
this is a rapid game so let's see how
the game continues first with Bishop
captures on f3 so giving up the light
square Bishop mess up dings pawn
structure and now rook F the c8 just
developing the rook and the bishop back
to e - so there is a game where Bishop
to f1 was played also a game where well
not that but f4 was played but Bishop to
e2 is a new move and it is as a move 16
that we have a completely new game on
our hands so as f4 was not played like
in the games we already mentioned viraja
prevents f4 by playing g5 so ding still
wants to play F or you want to play f4
bring your Bishop over to this diagonal
so he prepares it rook to d4 now f4
cappers will be met with rook captures
not there
and came to f8 now improving the
position of the king the king is coming
to e7 ding continues with his plan with
f/4g captures that's not a capture G
captures on f4 and knock rook captures
on f4 making room for the bishop on f3
kink the e7 and Bishop to f3 and here
you don't want to play something like
rook to b8 it's a very passive move
you're a long night to b5 so here better
is rook to g8 check this is what oh it
has a place King to f1 and now the other
rook comes to the opened e-file rook a
to DA so now the black rooks are much
more active and the blacks position is
excellent here with rook F back to d4
offering a trade and ali reza trades
with rook captures rook add force on d4
and now Knight C to d7 here Ali Rezai is
making room for his rook on the c5
square from c5 the rook will be a very
active peace with h3 biding in the now
rook the c8 s plan kingi to improving
the position of the king
Luke the c5 and now comes Luke to be for
now Dean wants to play rook to b5 and
offer a trade of rooks
with Knight to e5 now going after the
bishop every trade is in all the races
favor as as soon as he trades down and
gets this into a favorable drawn in
ending
let's say they can go into the second
second rapid game where Roger will have
the white pieces rule b5 as planned and
now Knight captures if you don't want to
trade here if you trade here then you
get Knight captures you already have
some targets on the Queen side so here
first night night that night Knight
captures an f3 King captures an f3 and
now 90 d7 saying okay we can try it but
we're gonna straight on c5 we have kingi
to biding a5 now and here F war we have
f5 by black and then out came to d3 and
now a fedora can no longer wait with his
rook and c5 for example a slow move will
be met with rook captures Knight
captures with Czech and now King is
already on c4 going to be 5 and you will
have problems here on the Queen side
so here Alireza goes back Luke to c6 and
now efore with 95 Czech preparing to
trade everything on e4 we have King III
and now F cat razani for the nightcap
trees on e4 Knight captures and Keane
captures and here came to f6 so here we
have seemingly are completely drawn and
game four pawns each three point islands
each one wrote each one King each and
well the only difference is dings
position is much more active his King is
more active you can see that he's
already sort of infiltrating in the
other half of the board and ferocious
rook is pretty much stuck here on these
two squares guarding the b6 bone so if
if King once he can claim a draw here if
you if he wants to try he can try and
grind well grind the position which he
will do as always is very long time
King f3 we have looked to d6 otherwise I
can only repeat these two moves and
maybe move Oh King here and there
kingi 4 we have ruled back to c6h4 now
look back to d6 + b3
King to g6 with a form ding improving
the position as much as he can before he
decides what he will do with King to
have six and now King to f3
rook the c6 and now King to e4 and here
route back to d6 so
if ding wants the row here he can draw
if he wants to try something he has to
allow the black rook to become active
and this is exactly what he does he
plays rook to h5 he gives black the
opportunity to activate his rook but
Alireza is not interested he plays came
to Jesus King to g6 pushing the rule
back we looked the g5 check King to f6
and now route back to b5 look back to c6
by frota in the now f5 trading this pawn
as well he captures rook captures with
Czech and came to g6 and now even h5
with check King to h6 and now came to d4
so now the rug doesn't have all that
much to do and the King is pretty much
stuck here on h6 and the g7 he has to go
by those two squares King to g7 we have
rook to g5 check King to h6 and now rook
back to d5 we have King to g7 and now
rook to e7 check King to h6 and now rook
to b7 dings idea is okay you can capture
on h5 I'm them gonna capture on h7 with
check and just return to b7 and here
best for all addresses rook to c8 you
have you have to give up the b6 point if
white will grab it for example if I
grabs it would check only then you grab
this pawn but you keep this pawn the
rook is no longer on b7 so now you have
a past age form I'll address on the
other hand played rook to f6 he decided
to just keep defending everything but
now he left a very crucial square
undefended the c-4 square and ding grabs
it now then is threatening King to b5
and here you have to prevent King to be
5 by playing rook to f3 with rook to f3
then if the King comes to b5 for example
if or you could capture here with the
check if King h5 then you will play rook
the b5 check King will go back in g4 and
now look at verse on a5 but now you have
h5 and you will start pushing pushing
your passport and fight for a draw this
way however all it has a played rook the
f4 check and now Dean gets the be 5
square with King to b5 King captures on
h5 and now rook captures on h7 with
check kingi 5 and now not capturing unbe
6 right away and allowing rook to be
three first look the b7 this is how we
want to capture this pawn rook the b4
check with King to a6 and now rook
captures on b3 I will look after some b6
and now of course if you trade this is a
winning position for ding so not an
option with rook back to d3 and here
doing plays King captures on a5 and
algirdas I played King to f5 here Ali
Rezai was extremely low in time I
believe below half a minute something
like that and dink had over ding he had
over three minutes on three and a half
minutes and ding is actually winning in
this position but there is only one move
that wins so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this winning idea
for doing while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations as no one
found this move
ding didn't find that Magnus didn't find
it who was you know joining in life with
young Gustafson and no one pretty much
found that the ideas came to b5 if you
found it then really you are just an
incredible end game player point is that
after King to b5 for King g5 you played
King to c6 and now after the route goes
after well the past pawn here you have
rook check King has to move and now a5
and your point is protected next you
just play King b7 and you promote the
pawn to a queen seems fairly simple but
the ding had three and a half minutes on
the clock he used 3 something minutes
and he didn't find he played King to a6
and then now King to e5 by firaga with
85 biding and now you have to play King
to d5 you have to take away the c6
square from white rook but here our reza
played rook to d7 and now as the c7 c6
square is free for dings rook ding just
played rook the c6 he made a room for
his King and now he's ready to push it
King d5 but now King D 5 is too late we
have Kingdom b6 and now rook to d8 going
after a it square but it is too late
maybe with a 6 rook to b8 check
going for some crazy tricks because here
you have to be careful for example you
could either go rook King c7 or King to
h7 problem would came to a 7 yes you're
hoping for captures captures and then
you promote this pawn into a queen but
after this scheme to h7 move black and
just play rugby to and now you will not
you will not have an easy time winning
this position for example if you try
something like let's say rugby 6 to go
after this rook you're gonna go rook f2
King b7 make room for a passed pawn
rugby rook F 7 check King see it you're
gonna go King C 5 attack the roof route
b7 you're gonna go rook f8 check King c7
you're gonna go rook to f6 ago after the
pawn and after a 7 now again rook f7
check King d8 offering a rook for a
queen but Luke f8 check and now finally
after King to e7 you're just gonna go
rook to a trait and the White has no way
of winning this you cannot move to a8 if
you go back with the Queen with the king
black will just repeat with the checks
if you don't do anything then you don't
win for example if you try this than
just rook h7 check will pick up the pawn
and a7 it's a very tricky idea so here
you have to be careful rook a king gauge
7 doesn't work King to c7 this is what
being played we have rook to e8 and now
King to b7 and it was in this position I
move 67 that holidays a ferocious
resigned the game the first rapid game
goes to dink as there is nothing more to
do here after you move the rook let's
say rotate a7 whatever you play check
you block you go there just queen and
now well it's it's just winning so yeah
really intense game and it just shows
that you know I wasn't was an excellent
player earlier a surfer rosa is you know
pushing dink to to his utmost limits to
find some winning ideas in completely
drawn positions and this is where Magnus
complimented him during his
I joined his call to the chess 24 a live
coverage he said that he was really
impressive how Dean was able to the
grind out this went out of a completely
drawn position something magnus carlsen
is always you know said of doing that he
will create something out of nothing
so here being definitely did create
something out of nothing it was in a
rapid game but still so that's a game
one I do hope you enjoyed it
game two is already being played I have
no idea what the position looks like as
I'm recording this video but probably we
will also be checking out game 2 so I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Alex lahrman for a contribute to
my channel thank you a lot that really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank y'all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World Cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and so on so thank you I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day